today we'll be explaining all straw hat
pirates in one piece there's a total of
11 interesting characters to cover and
we'll begin with everyone's favorite
captain monkey d luffy as captain of the
straw hat pirates luffy has the greatest
authority over an increasingly powerful
and diverse crew consisting of several
infamous members many of whom are
extremely powerful in their own right
luffy has a great amount of influence
over his crew so much so that the
members of his crew all trust him with
their lives both in spite of his
reckless behavior and in some cases even
because of it he's also one of the 12
pirates who've been dubbed as the worst
generation a group of individuals who
have become famous for the bold actions
and major conflicts they committed
against the world government and all
have bounties of over 100 million
bellies just quickly before we continue
if you guys are anime and manga fans i'd
like to present you something that you
will definitely love it's opera gx
browser which is the sponsor of today's
video i've never seen a browser that
allows users to customize their
experience as much as opera gx does you
can choose one of various special themes
wallpapers and colors or you can even
prepare everything from scratch and
upload your own background photos and if
that's not enough for you you can pick
one of the many animated wallpapers from
opera add-ons you ever found it
difficult to watch videos while doing
something else on your pc well opera gx
has a solution for you while watching a
video just click this button and the
video will split up from your browser
now you can do anything you want and
watch a video at the same time you can
also play music from your favorite
platforms directly from the sidebar
without searching for it every time the
music will stop as soon as you play
something else in your browser which
makes it pretty convenient i know that
switching browsers is hard but with
opera gx it's never been easier import
everything you need from your previous
browser in just a few clicks seriously
it's even faster than the anime time
skip use my link below to download opera
gx now and you'll even get the exclusive
feature that allows you to see my latest
uploaded videos in your gx corner thanks
to opera gx for sponsoring this video
and now let's continue luffy also has
claim over the straw hat grand fleet a
massive fleet consisting of seven
powerful new world crews numbering 5600
people in total who all swerve to serve
under him and will come to assist him
whenever he may need them he officially
became an emperor after defeating the
previous emperor kaido now recognized as
one of the four most powerful pirates in
the world luffy's raisin status caused a
panic around the world currently holding
a bounty of 3 billion bellies which
surpasses the current bounty of the
emperor blackbeard and equals the
bounties of two of his fellow members
from the worst generation kid in law his
bounty is only surpassed by the bounties
of the former emperor's whitebeard big
mom kaido fellow emperor shanks and the
late pirate king gold d roger himself
luffy has exhibited his threat most
notably by invading all three of the
world government's main strongholds in
paradise he defeated at least a thousand
marines on annie's lobby by himself and
took out two cp-9 agents with the
invasion ultimately resulting in the
destruction of enemy's lobby via buster
call he infiltrated the great prison
impaled down and orchestrated the only
mass breakout in its history and he also
invaded marine ford during the summit
war of marine fort and greatly aided the
whitebeard pirates in their ultimately
unsuccessful effort to rescue portgis
dies from execution luffy has also
significantly threatened the balance of
the three great powers by defeating
three members of the seven warlords of
the sea crocodile gecko maria and don
quijote doflamingo he also allied with
two others which caused jinbe to defect
from his position in troffelgar law to
lose his the world government also views
luffy to be a grave threat simply
because he's the son of monkey d dragon
the leader of the revolutionary army
despite his ever-growing list of
accomplishments in battle luffy
continues to be frequently
underestimated by opponents due to his
appearance and disposition this
oftentimes has ultimately proved to be
an advantage for him as it gives him
leeway towards options opponents would
not expect crocodile left luffy for dead
twice only for luffy to recover from his
defeats and ultimately claim victory in
their third match don quixote doflamingo
attempted to trap luffy in the korita
coliseum expecting that he would fall
victim in it only for luffy to escape
and win over the gladiators there to his
side what we're trying to say is don't
underestimate luffy currently in the new
world he has contented with the four
emperor's top commanders having defeated
big bomb pirates sweet commander
charlotte crackers and charlotte
katakuri and he seeks to aim further by
taking down the emperors themselves as
well as the marine admirals number 2
nami cat burglar nami is the navigator
of the straw hat pirates she's the third
member of the crew and the second to
join doing so during the orangetown arc
she's also the adoptive sister of nico
after the two were orphaned and taken in
by belmary she was formerly a member of
the arlong pirates and initially joined
the straw hats so that she could rob
them in order to buy back her village
from arlung however she legitimately
joined the straw hats after they
rebelled against and defeated arlung her
dream is to make a map of the entire
world she first gained a bounty of 16
million bellies for the incident at
annie's lobby and currently has a bounty
of 66 million bellies being the assigned
navigator of the straw hat pirates nami
is responsible for evaluating the
direction that the ship goes as they
sell further into the sea nami also
tends to act as the crew's de facto
treasurer managing the crew's money and
allocating spending whenever they arrive
at a new location besides sanji the
crew's trained chef nami is also the
only crew member known to possess even
basic cooking knowledge she also
possesses a strong enough willpower to
be able to withstand the burst of big
mom's hal shoku haki number 3. sanji
sanji is one of the crew's top three
fighters along with luffy and zorro and
is considered to be a member of the
monster trio of the straw hats due to
his great strength he currently has the
third highest bounty in the crew after
luffy and jimbei sanji usually fights
relying solely on his pure might and
skills without any weapons or devil
fruits in combat as a member of the
infamous vinsmoke family sanji was
raised and trained from an early age
alongside the rest of his siblings in
warfare and combat their father modified
them while their mother was still
pregnant in order to endow them with
superhuman abilities however due to
sora's own attempt at ensuring her sons
would keep their emotions she used a
counter drug and sanji's genetic
modifications were repressed therefore
he was born a normal human because of
this sanji couldn't keep up with the
extremely grueling germa training
resulting in his father's renouncement
of him however he ended up encountering
zeph a pirate captain turned chef who'd
teach him his own kickbase martial art
after joining the straw hat pirates he
could defeat fish men like kirobi
powerful assassins like mr2 and mighty
cp mine agents like jabra as a result
he's earned a bounty of 77 million
bellies before entering the new world
since returning from his training in the
kamabaka kingdom and entering the new
world sanji's strength has grown
exponentially and he's become an even
more powerful combatant able to fight
against some of the strongest pirates
and fighters there are after the
two-year time skip he was able to break
the stronger than steel neck of a
pacifista with a single diabetes jumbe
enhanced kick in contrast his leg would
have been seriously injured after using
the attack on a pacifist to pre-time
skip against charlotte oven sanji could
break his collarbone with a simple kick
while moving too fast for his eyes to
follow this is really impressive since
oven is gifted with the sturdiest body
of all the charlotte sons during the
raid on onigashima he and marco could
hold off two all-stars of the beast
pirates king and queen while buying
enough time for zord to recover
afterwards sanji could hold his own
against and temporarily overwhelm queen
a hand-picked top henchman of the
emperor kaido and an ancient zoan type
devil fruit user with a bounty of 1
billion 320 million bellies after
wearing the red suit multiple times
sanji's late and genetic modifications
were awakened during the same battle
which allowed him to fight against the
all-star on a more equal level and
finally defeat him using a powerful
combination of kicks number four uso
usope is the sniper the straw hat
pirates he's the fourth member of the
crew and the third to join doing so at
the end of the syrup village arc while
not on the same level as the rest of his
crew when it comes to pure physical mind
usop has learned to compensate for his
weaknesses by focusing on his own
strengths usop's endurance and willpower
is considerably strong being able to
take serious damage from powerful enemy
attacks after a major battle usop tends
to have severe injuries often caused by
his determination to reach his goal and
even with those injuries he'll attempt
to continue fighting prominent examples
of his incredible durability can be
observed when usopp was hit in the face
by mr four's four-ton bat and smashed
repeatedly through walls by miss merry
christmas he not only survived these
attacks but was able to continue
fighting also during the water 7 arc he
endured physical abuse from the frankie
family twice while trying to retrieve
the stolen money in thriller bark usual
was tough enough to withstand the
detonation of parona's exploding ghosts
multiple times and a ruthless beating
from komashi without losing
consciousness usope has also managed to
awaken his kenbon shoku haki during the
latter half of the dressrosa revolt and
he was able to see auras of luffy law
and sugar who were in the royal palace
with this he was able to pinpoint
sugar's location and sniper down from a
long distance number 5 zoro zorro has
devoted his life to becoming a powerful
swordsman and fighter and in his time as
a bounty hunter and later the combatant
of the straw hat pirates he has become
extremely well renowned for his
exemplary abilities and accomplishments
in battle by the time he met luffy zolo
had established himself as a fearsome
bounty hunter in the east blue so much
so that kobe had heard he was a demon in
the form of a man his accomplishments in
hunting pirates were significant enough
to earn him the epithet of pirate hunter
which he remains known by even after
becoming a pirate when zoro dueled
dracula mihawk his former partners were
completely confident that he would win
due to his dominance over east blue
opponents however zoro was utterly
outclassed by nihak a warlord of the sea
from the grand line since that defeat he
promised to never lose a battle again
alongside luffy and sanji zorro is
considered to be one of the monster trio
of the straw hats due to his strength
zoro's infamy has frequently been
treated a second only to his captain and
in some instances he has even been
mistaken as the leader of the straw hats
due to his more extensive reputation
zoro was the second straw hat member to
receive a bounty and for much of the
crew's existence his bounty had been the
second highest and is currently at 320
million bellies weaker people have been
shown to be easily intimidated by zorro
as kobe remarked that he had a demonic
aura at shellstown even when he was tied
up and starved to food for over a week
this is held shu even in the new world
as when monet came to suddenly realize
the degree of power and killing intent
zoro had she froze in place as zoro
charged her after zoro intentionally
performed a harmless attack she then
became seized by fear to such a degree
that she was unable to reform her lokia
body to its normal state when zoro gets
serious in a battle he usually dons his
black bandana on his head though whether
or not it had any real effect on his
abilities is uncertain ever since
entering the new world he has rarely
ever been wounded or given a serious
challenge his first genuine challenge
was a short confrontation with one of
the admirals isho who described his
slash attack as ferocious despite being
held down by gravitational force as the
first showcase of his greatly improved
strength and skills zorro defeated pika
one of the don quijote dove flamingos
top three executive officers he did this
in a couple of moves after slicing apart
his colossal stone body and figuring out
the nature of his devil fruit abilities
zaro suffered his first serious wound in
wano against kamazo albeit because he
avoided a surprise assault from gukimaru
while still managing to defeat the
manslayer using a single attack during
the raid on onigashima he faced off
against the emperor kaido famed as the
world's strongest creature in both his
beast and hybrid forms wounding him
despite the tremendous toughness of his
body number six tony tony chopper
typically it's rare for doctors to
fulfill roles other than medical
practices but as the straw hat pirate's
doctor chopper's responsibilities are
not limited to just medicine alone he
occasionally performs tasks like
steering the ship as their unofficial
helmsman while on the going mary also
during the heat of battle he can fulfill
the role of a physical fighter to
support his friends however due in part
to his lack of battle experience or
formal training chopper was originally
considered part of the weakling trio
along with nami and usopp this is
largely due to his lack of battle
intuition and naivety at the same time
though it's shown that he's gotten much
more capable after his two years of
training on trevino kingdom during the
whole cake island arc chopper showed
great tactical skills yet again in the
middle of his confrontation with
charlotte bray as he and carrick came up
with a method to deceive her using a
decoy he pretended to remain restrained
by chains in his heavy point and when
carrot toppled the soup towards brulee
chopper used the element of surprise by
changing into brain point to break free
before using monster point subjugating
the crocodile homie and wiping out the
remaining enemies number 7 jinbei as the
second captain of the sun pirates jinbei
is an extremely powerful pirate and a
former member of the seven warlords of
the sea with high authority and respect
over his subordinates it's stated the
jimbei was able to battle porcus dies on
equal terms despite ace possessing logia
powers they both nearly killed each
other in a five day long fight just
before ace was taken in by whitebeard
his power and influence are so great
that him departing from one of the four
emperor's organization would severely
diminish their crew's overall strength
even cp9 agents commented on his
strength and believed he was capable of
killing who's who a former cp9 agent and
one of the strongest shinnuchi of the
beast pirates he was the first and only
fishman to become a warlord with a
considerable bounty of 250 million
bellies reflecting the danger the world
government believes he possesses after
his resignation from the seven warlords
participation in impelled down's first
ever mass breakout and the summit war of
marine ford it was raised to 438 million
bellies jinbei also has a very acute
sense of danger as he refused to spin
big mom's roulette after sensing
murderous malice from the roulette it's
later confirmed by pedro and belay that
the roulette had been rigged to ensure
death to anyone who spun it jinbe is
also able to completely suppress any
emotions of fear which renders him
immune to big mom's ability to take away
a person's lifespan number 8. nico robin
at a young age robin acquired a bounty
of 79 million bellies for having the
ability to read pornoglyphs which told
her the void sentry her ability to read
the poneglyphs is by far her most
valuable quality and the world
government considers her a huge threat
because of this this has also made her a
vital target for those who understand
the significance of the poneglyphs
mainly for those who want to gain
control of the ancient weapons and the
means to find laugh tales including the
likes of kaido and big mom due to her
having to spend her life on the run from
multiple organizations mostly the
marines in the world government robin
had developed into a strong and
resourceful woman after two years of
training with the revolutionary army
robin has grown more stronger in every
way sanji one of the strongest members
of the straw hat pirates was willing to
call for robin's help when he was
trapped by black maria despite knowing
that she was the beast pirate's target
showing he has complete confidence in
robin's abilities his faith was proven
to be well placed when robin defeated
black maria number 9. frankie as a
member of the straw hat pirates frankie
is a competent and powerful crewmate as
well as a valuable asset for the crew
being their official shipwright frankie
is in charge of maintaining the thousand
sunny's condition along with the other
vehicles instruments or weapons that the
straw hats may employ after completing
his studies on katakuri island over the
course of two years and returning to his
crew frankie's considerable fighting
skills have increased greatly in tandem
with his engineering abilities frankie
while piloting the general frankie was
able to easily defeat the giant squid
fish man ikaros much knocked the
artificially produced ancient giant and
emerged victorious over baby five in
buffalo without his mech suffering
anything more than a simple puncture
wound even after enduring an extended
beating to his upgraded cyborg body
frankie retained enough strength to
overpower senior pink an assassin in the
don quixote pirates it was only against
sasaki an ancient zone type devil fruit
user with a bounty of
472 million bellies but the iron pirate
received some serious damage although
frankie was able to land a conclusive
attack after a lengthy battle
additionally frankie has considerable
skills in playing a guitar number 10.
brooke as much as brooke normally goofs
around on the ship engaging in acts of
silliness with luffy he's still a
formidable opponent due to his previous
experience and skills that he amassed
from the days when the pirate king
goldie roger was still active brook in
all respects is a veteran pirate when he
first met the straw hats he quickly
proved to be a very valuable person to
them most notably during their
encounters with thriller bark's many
undead inhabitants after the time skip
brooke's overall skills had proven to be
a very important asset during battle as
he defeated the energy steroid-powered
zeo with no difficulty and cut down
guiola of the don quijote pirates when
fighting to reclaim the thousand sunny
he and tony tony chopper battled and
defeated several of big mom's chess
soldiers this earned them praise from
charlotte karakuri one of big mom's
sweet commanders he also got the idea to
store the copies of big mom's poneglyphs
inside his head before she captured him
he also disguised himself as a clone of
luffy to take advantage of the chaos
when luffy crashed big mom's tea party
and he destroyed big mom's portrait of
carmel without being noticed same as
some of the other crew members we
covered so far brooke was shown to have
a strong willpower as he was able to
withstand a burst at big mom's haushogu
haki number 11. neverthelebe as a
princess vivi has a great deal of
authority in her country as well as
natural skill and diplomacy when meeting
the straw hats she managed to persuade
zoro and nami into protecting her from
the baroque works agents after her cover
was blown and even persuaded nami not to
charge her for their protection when
traveling with the straw hats she even
showed an impressive and almost comedic
amount of skill in keeping the more
childish members of the crew focused
calm and motivated during their travels
together since leaving the straw hats
she seems to have managed to maintain
her role as a princess all the while
successfully keeping both her past as a
baroque work agent and a companion of a
pirate crew secret from the marines in
the world government